just me star bunch I'm not gonna answer  star much on May 5th what you see you  only get one chance to save the galaxy  twice Oh No and almost hit me  guardians of the galaxy vol 2 vide PG 13  the sovereign the Ravagers they all want  us dead that's a really bad sign the  guardians must be destroyed  hit me with your best shot  oh wow I know and almost hit me get  tickets now  crowd put your seatbelt on  [Laughter]  so here we are  a thief one thugs and assassin a maniac  and an angry little treat  [Music]  no we're saving the galaxy again  guardians cannot protect the galaxy from  oh there must be some kind of peaceful  resolution to this or even a violent one  where I'm standing over there  guardians of the galaxy vol 2 get  tickets now the wealdian imax 3d  you